prince harry was incredibly close to
prince philip
you know there were soldiers they shared
a love of the military
and i think you can just tell from the
tone of harry's statement
um in which he pays such a warm tribute
to his grandfather
just how much he loved him and like all
members of the royal family
will really be missing him right now i'm
told he is of course
as you would expect very upset missing
his grandfather
but also relieved to be here in the uk
and happy to be here and and looking
forward to being reunited
with his family it's going to be an
emotional
reunion and he hasn't seen his family
for over a year now
so i think many people are thinking
there is a silver lining in all of this
that
finally there will be a family reunion
we know that
william and harry have had a lot of
problems over the past year
and not least in the last month in the
fallout
of harry and megan's oprah interview i
think everyone's hope is that this is
going to be
an opportunity for william and harry to
spend some time together they haven't
actually seen each other now for over a
year you know
zoom conversations telephone
conversations simply aren't the same as
being together
so this is the first real opportunity
that they are going to have
to sit down together and talk
and hopefully start to
build a better relationship we don't
know how long prince harry's going to be
staying in the uk we don't know how
fleeting a trip
this is going to be but i think the hope
is that there will be
an opportunity at the right time for the
brothers to sit down
and talk i think people are hoping that
in all of this very sad story that there
may be a silver lining and that will be
that william and harry can start to talk
about things
and hopefully put the past behind them
and move on
suddenly i think that's what the duke of
edinburgh would have wanted he was a
family man he was the patriarch
of the royal family he loved william and
harry
and he would have hated to have seen
them fall out well i think as hard as it
was
for prince harry to leave his heavily
pregnant wife behind
um actually it may not be such a bad
thing that he is here
on his own and you know he won't have
anyone else to
worry about this is just him with his
family
and hopefully there will be an
opportunity in in what is going to be a
very
busy and emotional and intense weekend
hopefully there will be a time for some
much-needed
one-on-one time with his father with
prince william
and with the queen
there will just be 30 guests at prince
philip's funeral and this is because
of the covert pandemic and government
guidelines
so it's a small guest list which will
comprise
mostly uh immediate family some extended
family
and a few of prince philip's closest
aides but had we not been in a pandemic
this wasn't going to be a state funeral
but it would have been a bigger funeral
than what we were expecting on saturday
with probably around
800 guests so aids have been working on
reducing that guest list crunching it
down
to 30 and of course it will be the queen
who has
the overall sign off on who's going to
be
at st george's chapel on saturday prince
harry is
already in the uk he is here he is um in
isolation on quarantine at frogmore
cottage which is of course the couple's
uk base so what sort of a homecoming is
it going to be for prince harry
well a deeply emotional one i think that
much we can be sure of
i'm sure that he's desperate to see his
grandmother the queen of course
the sussex's cottage frogmore cottage is
a very short walk
from windsor castle it's literally a
stone's throw but because of kobe prince
harry simply can't see
the queen for the next five days he has
to self-isolate
but of course given what has happened
and what the queen is going through i
would imagine that she is
probably the first person he will want
to see
as soon as he's been given me all clear
you